- Good morning. Carpe Diem.
Fightin' them cavities. Haha.
This is my jam.
Yeah, Wednesday! Humpday, ya'll. Hey.
Beautiful.
Getting' ready to see my girl.
She takin' forever, though.
- It smells weird. Did
you have pizza in here?
What are you looking at?
- What?
- What are you looking at?
- Don't put everything on Snapchat! Jesus!
You need to get a life!
Are you filming me right now?
Are you filming me?
- No, I'm not!
- Drink with me, Don.
- [Justin] I can't, I'm driving.
- You're driving?
- [Justin] Hey, Zack, get
out from behind the bar.
- Oh, I'm a bartender. What do ya want?
- [Voiceover] Hey, kid, stop it!
Get the fuck out of my bar right now!
- [Justin] Yo, we gotta go!
Oh, Zack, no!
- Dude, I don't feel good,
bro. Just go without me.
- [Justin] What do you mean?
- Just go, dude, I need
to find a bathroom.
- Oh no. I just hit this car.
- Hey buddy! What's your problem man,
you just hit my car!
What are you Snapchatting and driving?
Give me that! Give me that!
- Whoa, this dude just
put me in his trunk. What?
I think I just got kidnapped.
I'm in his basement, I think.
- Justin! I'm here to break you out!
Is this Snapchat?
- Yeah.
- Hey, what's up everybo--
- [Voiceover] Hey, get back here!
- [Justin] Zack! Zack, no!
- I've been shot! I just got shot!
- [Justin] Go. Just
go, just go peacefully.
- It's 3 o'clock in the morning, Justin.
It's 3 o'clock in the
morning, I just can't.
And you're doing this again, please.
- [Justin] Something happened with Zack.
- Something happened.
You gotta be kidding me.
I'm leaving you.
- Yo, these tacos are bomb!
So good.